[Music]
all right let's go to
marie in detroit hey marie what's going
on
hey how are you dr d i'm good how are
you
doing okay i'm kind of sleep deprived so
just bear with me
we have a little one how old um okay
he our littlest is seven months oh
you're super sleep deprived
yeah how about this i have a great idea
how about don't even ask a question you
can just put your head down
and just sleep for 10 minutes and we'll
just have silence on the podcast
that sounds great all right go ahead
what's up
okay so okay we kind of have an
interesting situation here so we have
five kids our oldest
is eight he is adopted from foster care
um and he has some pretty severe mental
illness
and like abuse in his past
um so actually at this point he's not
even living in our homes
due to the severity of his behaviors and
this has just been like
super difficult for our family for me
and my husband
um and we're just kind of grieving that
he's not here
and my question is like my husband and i
are not grieving the same
yeah and it's been really difficult on
our marriage
so i guess we're just looking for some
advice on like
the mismatched grief and just how to
like navigate yeah that's awesome
thanks for that question um so you got
five kids eight and under
yeah and one of them is he in a home now
yeah he is okay um was he violent
hurting himself was he okay yeah yeah
and are your other four kids are they
biological they're adopted too
um they're biological okay so you
adopted
who came first what was the order yeah
we adopted first
okay um and so when you say grief is
mismatched that's a super
common challenge um but before we get
into that i just want
you to exhale for a second and you live
in a really
really chaotic home and that's okay
but i want you to give you and your
husband some grace right now because
what feels like
is channeled towards grieving
differently is probably both of you all
responding to chaos differently
you got five kids under eight or eight
and under
that's a hurricane i got two and i don't
even know what day it is
yeah right that's a lot a lot a lot did
y'all plan all five of these
yeah we did we did we just like have
always wanted to have a big family
awesome um and yeah it's just been
tricky as the oldest one his
behaviors have just kind of gotten more
and more severe he's gotten older and
so one day and we were like oh man
walk me through how y'all are grieving
differently
um i mean honestly for me like i'm just
being really vulnerable i've been like
devastated some days i can't
get out of bed it's like really down and
my husband kind of just acted like he
just kind of had to be the rock
so he's just like trucking along doing
life
and i think it's just tricky because i'm
like
are you sad are you okay like you know i
don't know we just i feel like we're
just on different levels right now
um so yeah um
so are you resenting the fact that he
can get out of bed
and i'm not i'm not saying that in the
mean way i'm saying that in a is this
does it feel like he doesn't care as
much as you do that you lost your son
maybe uh yeah maybe is he frustrated
with you that he just wants you to snap
out of it let's get to it we got four
other kids around here we got to get up
and going
definitely not no he's like amazing and
it's like you
do whatever you need to do i'm here to
support you you you know i'm
here for you so so let me promise you
this
your husband's heartbroken too
and he may look at a situation where
he's got a
wife that he loves with a newborn and
like he said he had to go into rock mode
to make sure the bills are getting paid
and kids are getting fed
and that's okay but it sounds like you
need to give him space to grieve
and some people just
don't fall apart i do i'm somebody that
needs some time
some people aren't they just don't and
some people fall apart to where they
they fall apart fall apart right
have y'all sit down and talk to each
other about the grief
yeah i mean we've tried and he decides
that he feels like okay and he just
i think he's more at peace with the
decision than
i am yeah
so i want to ask you a hard question
that's to a sleep deprived mother of a
newborn which is really not cool
um how would you like him to be grieving
differently
what would make you feel like he's
grieving the right way
i don't know i i guess i just
i don't know i don't know what it would
look like but maybe just be like
more i i guess
what i don't like about it is it makes
me feel very distant from him because i
feel
like we're not in unison on it and
maybe that's the hardest part like i
want to feel like we're kind of
conquering it together
and it says it feels like i'm kind of in
the valley and he's
on the hill like hey you're gonna be
okay yeah
does that make sense yeah
um so the way i would reframe it is
you are in it together both of you lost
your son man
and y'all were trying to do the a really
noble and remarkable thing through
adoption
and it's hard
hard hard hard you're super in it
together what i'd love for you to do is
to paint a picture of what you think his
grief should look like
and what your grief feels like and let
him do the same thing
and just because it doesn't look the
same doesn't mean you're not together
my guess is you're much more if you
remember back to the very first
biological kid you had
at seven months i don't know any couple
that feels totally in sync together
relationally
right that's just a season of distance
and so
expect that and i don't want you to take
what's happening with that seven month
old and
lay it on top of what's happening with
your son right
those may be two separate processes you
may be healing
man your body still is not yours and
then your husband's running around
but dude i think y'all are really close
into this together
when you say you feel distant what does
that mean
um i think i feel
i don't know maybe like guilty that i'm
struggling so much and that like he can
be so
okay there it is right there
it's not about him this is about you
yeah dude i didn't even have to say it
that makes my heart feel good way to go
you're way down the road marie
enlisted your grief gets to be your
grief
and it sounds like you got a pretty
remarkable guy standing by you saying
you grieve however you need to grieve
is that fair yes oh yeah
is he trying to solve you all the time
and fix stuff or is he just letting you
be
no he's he's amazing he's just like i i
got the kids i got dinner
you do what you need to do i'm here for
you he's amazing
okay so here's what i want you to do
you've raised five
and grown four
you for the first time probably in a
long time put both of your shoulders
down
and just relax into that dude's arms
you get to grieve however you need to
grieve
okay you are worth grieving
do you believe that yeah
like i said i think i feel guilty
because you know we afford the little
ones that need us and
i still feel guilty that i couldn't help
our older son
stay in our home you know and there's
there's just a lot it's a
hard situation yeah you gotta put that
gill brick down
yeah will you do me a huge favor
in the evenings before you go to bed and
if your husband would do this with you
it'd be awesome
i want you to write down some of those
feelings actually write them all down
they'll be about 10 or 15.
it'll take about 10 minutes to do this
but write them down
i'll let my son down
i didn't whatever today i was a pretty
good mom today
i was a pretty good wife today i want
you to write those feelings down
and then with your husband i want y'all
to mine those for evidence
and i want you to say him out loud and
look them in the eye when you see them
and say
tell me if this is true or false
and all you're doing is you are feeling
those feelings you're allowed to feel
them they're real
you can't deny them you can't depress
them down
but also you've got to begin to learn to
not let them run your life
because some of them aren't true
you didn't fail a son your son in fact
you're continuing to take care of him
you're not failing your two-year-old by
grieving you're not feeling your
four-year-old by grieving you're not
feeling your seven-month-old by grieving
you're not feeling your husband by
grieving okay
but you're gonna need him to look in the
eye and smile and say nope
i love you okay
okay you promise
yeah i do excellent marie you're a rock
star mom
he's lucky to have you and
man i can't even wrap my head around
what it'd be like to lose a kid
they have to send the child away because
they were violent in my home they
weren't safe
heartbreaking should have done this i
could have done that man
if you get to a place where you can't
get out of bed
where the weight and the heaviness just
gets heavier and heavier and heavier
please please reach out to your doctor
reach out to a counselor in your
community go get
some external support there okay
but you get to grieve how you grieve
you have permission and grief thank you
so much marie